it's become a military operation German
soldiers called in to help barish this
garden we're a state of emergency has
been declared the Bavarian town hasn't
seen snow like this for years and the
dangers are all too real we have many
requests to help clear the roofs of
buildings in the town of by device and
how 13 years ago 15 people died many of
them children when a roof collapsed it's
important to keep a close eye on the
roofs and secure any that pose a danger
heavy snowfall has completely cut off
the southern German town of Yakka now it
may look like a perfect picture postcard
but there are increasing concerns that
food supplies are running low in
Switzerland guests were lucky to survive
an avalanche that came crashing through
their hotel photos on social media
showed the devastation as the 300 metre
avalanche swept into the building at the
Shafaat Gap mountain pass injuring three
people in the mountains around Innsbruck
in Austria they too are on avalanche
standby there are concerns that if the
weather improves people may take
unnecessary risks yes I understand feel
it the fear is that people will say well
there is a lot of snow the weather is
better and our experience from the last
30 years has shown that the first day of
improved weather is really dangerous
it's when most Avalanche accidents
happen more than 4 meters of snow has
already fallen in this region for those
living here the hard work looked set to
last sometime yet in DWS I mean SF is
covering the story for us from A to Z in
Austria which is struggling with extreme
snowfall well it snowed again last night
and I wouldn't be exaggerating if I said
that this city this town is completely
buried when you go through the streets
that gives the impression of walking
through a tunnel I mean the the walls of
snow are
literally twice as tall as I am the the
headline this morning in the local
newspaper was hope and trepidation hope
would probably describe this side of the
the village
I mean I'll say which has had some of
the heaviest snowfall but the villagers
are really dealing with it the bakery is
open the hotel is open people are
walking through the streets there's not
snowplows they don't have snow plows
here actually they have they have
shovels steam shovels going through the
streets literally carrying the snow
because there's nowhere to put it they
have to put it in giant piles down the
street
now trepidation would describe the other
side of this village about a kilometre
down the street there they have been
evacuated it's completely closed off no
one's allowed to go there and that's
because of the danger of avalanches
Austrian authorities have history issued
the highest avalanche warning for that
area even the mayor had to evacuate his
house I don't know if you can hear but
there's a helicopter flying overhead and
what those helicopters are doing are
checking the situation to see if an
avalanche is about to to go down and so
people had to get out of that area
you